cette étude nous vient de
grande-bretagne elle concerne les
enfants qui utilisent les téléphones
portables le risque n'est pas anodin
estiment les experts britanniques même
si aucune certitude définitive de
prévaut en la matière alors attention
normes aussi pour les adolescents c'est
un accessoire essentiel de la vie en
groupe
pour les parents c'est un lien rassurant
avec leur progéniture mais pour les
scientifiques britanniques les
téléphones portables sont surtout un
danger potentiel pour la santé des
enfants est pris à l'ombre et je vais
utiliser un téléphone portable
normalement c'est à dire comme pour la
plupart des gens moins de deux minutes
il n'y a aucun problème mais les
problèmes commencent quand vous utilisez
cet objet à fort rayonnement près de
votre tête pendant plus de 20 minutes
là il peut y avoir des dégâts sur votre
organisme
selon une étude de l'institut national
de protection des ondes radioélectriques
c'est parce que leur système nerveux est
en cours de développement
et parce que les tissus de leur cerveau
absorbe davantage les rayonnements que
les enfants pourraient être plus
vulnérables aux ondes émises et reçues
par les portables particulièrement
exposés les moins de 9 ans qui serait
750000 en grande bretagne en posséder un
j'ai vu les mises en garde qui montre à
quel point les portables peuvent
perturber notre cerveau notre avenir et
notre audition en vertu du principe de
précaution les scientifiques
britanniques recommande donc et la
prudence face à l' usage immodéré des
téléphones portables par les moins de 14
ans conversations courtes et sms aussi
souvent que possible
une prudence qui non seulement sera
bonne pour la santé des enfants mais
aussi pour le portefeuille des parents